welcome in to this rapid game courage TF
maybe the way to pronounce that so um
yeah 93 okay let's go yeah that's kinda
96 these kind of lines are getting
popular I think Knight d4 is the usual
move now Bishop c4 for white let's see I
think black plays like that I think d5
there is some trick there is some tricky
takes it takes 94 c 495 this this kind
of trick is there so probably not a good
idea so just a 6 & a 6 45 okay what to
do here let's see 60 probably not sure
how useful a success here in that
position but anyway yeah his ideas
prolly to play with f4 f5
maybe this one that looks useful in most
cases if he goes F for a hefty five that
looks a bit I know it looks mistimed I
have a hefty five now and if he goes
Bishop b3 I take e for ya winning
basically if he has to take then f4
doesn't really belong in that position
opening up the e-file with those
weaknesses I don't know ok yes f5 as a
possible move but now that should be ok
for black pawn to f5 that is really the
only way for him to justify the whole
thing I wonder if I should go a
five-year myself to block that 9797
maybe an idea it's a bit slow that's
what I dislike about it but ok right
it's interesting
so yeah um that was a very sloppy play I
was thinking I could even go h5 here
soon but you will just take that happily
night f5 you will take like Queen f3
should be a bit more focused him g6
that's ugly but I guess I have to
guess i guess i have to g6 it's not very
nice so yeah this h5 move now right
let's do that I 12 h 4 and 9 f five if I
get that in without any repercussion I'm
certainly okay um Shep g4 here to get
the Queen to have to then aged for 90 to
95 interesting position each reach for
now I think that it sets fine
so each form is dropping back to e2 I
guess and a half 95 very weird position
but term not bad probably there's also a
ch3 here that mix yeah why not h3
playing a bit quick to quickly actually
for that time control word I mean I
think it's okay 94 taking on g2 is
really awkward for what take you on d
for hd2
uh huh that's interesting
maybe now 94 is an option
maybe I should just protect that default
porn with the muffler Queen to be six
and also prepares to Casa long
and what so not so sure just taking on
g2 now that that's probably not not
well-timed Queen B 6 is fine be strange
if not
he for okay yeah let's get that King out
of here on 85 I have a queen f6 keeping
that protected and I mean the thing is
my position is was a tiny bit shaky man
but if there's nothing drastic happening
in one or two moves I'm just winning
this because the his his pieces are
terrible on d 2 B 3 and so on and i got
i just got a king king attack on his
King so it's either yeah failing to some
to something or White is falling apart
okay so taking you for even even more
yeah night night f5 looks completely
normal so let's do it not second-guess
too much
look on a4 is really far off from any
defense of the King so
I have a couple of ideas just taking on
g2 was the easiest one okay he prevented
this um okay this means that rupee eight
gets high on the list of moves to
consider the other thing is that he
might have c3 at some point and I wonder
maybe you should maybe I should just do
this now so that I'm not in a check like
if you go see three I can just take c3
Quincy five takes on d2 and i still can
go what i wanted to do like rook e8 and
some pileup on the e-file there's no
hurry with that
hmm what are you doing before probably
okay not much that I can do about it
let's pile up on the e-file that should
be right his ruckus as mentioned really
far off on a forum
so over here
it's difficult to suggest anything here
for watching I can go b5 trying to stir
some trouble p 5 i'll take it group
before but if I just play something like
rupee 7 rupee five other rook to e8 I
don't see him okay d5 hangs but I don't
I don't think you can survive that I
also have rookie three that this
additional idea oh that looks low it
looks really slow okay um let me follow
up on that idea rookie three threads
rook f3 that's nice he takes it pawn
takes it has to go Queen chef one head
looks immensely awkward but maybe not
not winning okay the easiest is to
double let's do that it was the original
intention
that's very relaxed her you know what
are you doing now okay so I wasn't
thinking it he can survive that but
maybe again so um let's check how to do
that
93 years so pretty good for possible 91
I take it Queenie six Bishop detour Oh
am i winning from there don't see yet
how
hmm
93 is probably enough but it feels like
I should be something better
don't don't see it though I don't see
anything much better rookie 3 is also
very tempting rookie 34 queen is 6 minus
all that's hard to imagine how he would
defend their look III Bishop g5 maybe
well then Queenie 7 we should be fun
hmm I'd really like to find something
that ends the game right here and don't
see it may be Queen d6 then-rookie three
come on let's play that way a bit too
impatient you have to admit maybe
yes sir I don't really see a quick move
maybe look a one also trying to connect
troops
I played some sloppy more Sam rook a one
looks am quite sensible
my idea was to play look III next but I
don't even sure of that net so much
ok to TKE sit
I promise whatever he moves that night
is rookie too so it's exceptionally
difficult to coordinate that position in
some way still I don't see exactly how
I'm winning
yeah look a one look sensible it's a bit
it doesn't have many moves don't I don't
really know how to finish this off as
terrible as it looks
yeah maybe really Knightly 3d one this
had that idea earlier
ignitee 319 one Knight c3 and invading
with that piece my queen is not able to
enter at the moment if it could do that
enter the position will probably be over
but I don't see don't see how
yeah tough to commentate rook rook rook
a one I still don't see any other
sensible move trying to somehow get the
rook back into the game 93 maybe then
what you cannot take it te 3 then wins
quite easily and I go 91 next
okay um that doesn't really change
anything so let's let's go there and use
that night for something 91
oh yeah it tries to prepare um be five
maybe okay 91 Queen f1 and 993 would
even attack that neuer that Bishop heads
it's awkward okay let's do it I see a
funny wind by the way Queen F 1 93 let's
play that Bishop takes pawn takes King
edge one rookie one Queenie one Bishop
f3 mate that's it's quite cute it's a
bit difficult to avoid them I mean okay
the bishop on a for now is a very
unlucky or unfortunate unfortunate piece
b5 nite a4 b6 something like that but
maybe I probably have something
something better even
even in some cases just 92 a check will
probably win
you
yeah he went forth for that
continuations also Bishop before imma
take on a phone okay i think if i take
it Bishop takes Knight it will check
King on the king in the corner i take c
1 and then invade only to where should
that should summer end the game and I
don't don't believe that he can survive
this and yeah come on let's take it ID
to check night exit to look sexy too
there were anything anything better
um check not sure that should be enough
okie on proof is moving the king of an
idea not right made they don't see it
losing but feels weird
yeah he plays it back rank wait I can
take on c1 now Bishop Jake's should f3
chick
okay Oh Oh is there something else let's
check briefly and push up f3 would be
made but he's covering that ok let's
take on see 10 is God Bishop before
should I have taking that into account
probably Edward would affirm bin Tarawa
but still okay so how to how to do that
now rookie to threaten special f3 yeah
so let's do that
white resins chairman probably with good
reason it still feel like pressure could
have done something better okay so we
started here I was surprised that he
went f5f for because it looks it looked
to me that it felt wrong that he had
this situation with the open e file
where were those squares a week but um
yeah it's not all roses for black as
well or either yeah I was attended h5
yeah that's just silly you will very
happily take that or even this move
thought so terrible okay I went here and
now the engine suggests SEF I have I
suspected that there might be something
like that but mm-hmm because I really
this is a very blah Chad's got a lot of
holds this position this this that gives
him a huge attack I have five four
strong him went here and each five here
and now the tables start to start to
turn yeah the engine wants to take on g2
maybe em but I felt like protecting
shouldn't be bad oh it wasn't a good
idea check I overlooked this idea I
played I played this very superficially
at that point very awkward it's a funky
line though it's not so bad for black
the funny okay went a for now I can get
along and here it starts to become
very nice for me maybe I should have
taken now I not play night at five but
the position he has very good King b8
was kind of a safe move and don't think
it's bad to spend that tempo yeah he and
I t3 was already winning yeah I have
this idea also now in that Ted wins so
that was a bit better than what I did
here there's also rookie three winning
check okay round here the positioning
becomes so good that I have a couple of
strong things and the engine gives gives
me a complete win yeah here probably not
a force is easier but I felt that this
should win as well now and it does if he
takes it rook takes bishop here check do
something like that threatening this
it's just not defensible this happened
and here he resigned yeah and there's no
move if he goes like f5 yeah I'm
checking him check this is check mate
and King here check checkmate is quite
cute yeah and that is the threat or the
threats let's say
yeah so it's a quite quite hopeless so
we resigned yeah I hope you enjoyed that
game thanks for watching